As you may know, if you've been paying attention
to the news for the last few days, votes are
still being counted in the 2020 presidential
election and Joe Biden's lead over Donald
Trump has now actually surpassed five million
votes.
And this is, I think, a really good time to
add some context to these numbers, because
depending on what historical context you prefer
to add, the sort of takeaways from Joe Biden's
current popular vote win would be pretty dramatically
different.
So with Joe Biden at close to seventy seven
million votes and Donald Trump at close to
72 million votes, the exact lead for Joe Biden
as of moments ago was about five point zero
seven million votes.
In other words, five million plus seventy
thousand votes.
And when you look back at the history of presidential
elections, this is not even close to the largest
winning margin.
If you're looking at some of the historical
landslides, for example, if you look at Richard
Nixon's historic 17 million vote margin in
1972, if you look at Ronald Reagan's in 84
by 16 million votes, LBJ and FDR won by 15
and 11 million votes, respectively.
Even Barack Obama won by more than nine million
votes in 2008.
But needless to say, this is a healthy margin
for Joe Biden.
And all of the huge wins that I mentioned
just now came with far larger electoral victories
as well.
And that's something not to be ignored.
Now, a really interesting fact is that among
the largest popular vote losses among candidates
who won, in other words, popular vote lost
won the presidency electorally.
Donald Trump's popular vote loss in 2016,
which was, as you remember, by about three
million votes to Hillary Clinton, is the largest
popular vote loss in history for a candidate
who won the Electoral College.
And it's followed by George W. Bush losing
the popular vote by about half a million in
the year 2000 to Al Gore and still winning
electorally, as you remember, Florida, the
decider in that particular election.
For me, the most interesting perspective on
the numbers so far is that Joe Biden has fifty
point eight percent of the vote right now.
And when you look at challengers, which accounts
for the power of incumbency, remember, removing
an incumbent president is really difficult,
even an unpopular one, 2004.
And George W. Bush's reelection is a strong
reminder of that among presidential challengers
to an incumbent.
Joe Biden's fifty point eight percent, which
may still go up, is the highest vote share
for a challenger to an incumbent president
dating all the way back to Franklin Delano
Roosevelt in 1932, who got 57 percent of the
vote as the challenger in 32.
And in fact, it's higher at fifty point eight.
Joe Biden's share of the vote is higher even
than Ronald Reagan's, which was fifty point
seven in 1980.
So needless to say, it's a very healthy win,
popular vote.
And yet it came down to a combined razor thin
margin of, you know, we're waiting on the
Georgia results.
But as of right now, we're talking about 70000
votes in Nevada and Pennsylvania.
Or you could put it a different way and say
Joe Biden won thanks to sixty thousand votes
in Pennsylvania and Arizona, depending on
what you consider the winning states for Joe
Biden.
So what can we say?
More generally?
We can say that Donald Trump's two elections
taken together are remarkable.
Trump lost the popular vote twice, is one
of only 10 incumbents to lose reelection and
one of only three presidents to be impeached.
And if you sort of make a Venn diagram of
this, which people have done and have shared
on social media, if you take this together,
Donald Trump is the only president to lose
the popular vote twice, be removed after one
term and be impeached.
So that's quite a resume for him now.
Is there a bigger story than just trivia?
There is, but it really depends on your perspective.
So on the one hand, how did Joe Biden manage
to almost lose the Electoral College in the
middle of the worst president in the modern
eras, globally embarrassing handling of a
100 year pandemic?
Joe Biden almost didn't win.
That's not good.
On the other hand, even with Republican voter
suppression, Republican voter purges trumps
election disinformation, attempted sabotage
of the postal service.
Even with all of that, Joe Biden still won
by more than five million votes and may end
up with the exact number of.
Rural votes 306, as Donald Trump had in 2016,
depending on what ultimately happens in Georgia.
My view is both of these things are true.
We have to be a what what right wing pseudo
intellectual said reality of the world is
messy or something like that.
We can hold both ideas at the same time.
We have to take the wins where we got them,
which is that Joe Biden won, period.
And we have to now improve going forward.
We have to pour everything we have into the
two Senate runoff races in Georgia, which
we will be talking about quite a bit tomorrow,
and realize that it was close when it came
down to not the five million votes, but the
under 100000 votes that the winning states
ended up depending on.